et tout d'abord la dernière histoire de
mickey la petite souris qui broyait du
noir et qui s'est mise rouge
euro disney vient en effet d'autoriser
le vin dans les restaurants du parc
d'attractions de marne-la-vallée
une première qui rompt avec la tradition
sobriété en vigueur chez disney est
d'ailleurs tout cela bien sûr c'est une
nouvelle opération séduction de la
clientèle européenne qui boude un peu
milk et christelle meyrals ils devaient
les dernières attractions d'eurodisney
son temps peu plus française vins bières
et champagne ont fait leur apparition
une véritable petite révolution chez
mickey car lors de la création du parc
il ya plus d'un an
l'alcool avaient été bannis dont le
royaume purée magique de mickey pas la
moindre goutte n'avaient droit de cité
mais voilà française européens ont
contesté ce régime sec
il en avait assez de voir partout des
tonneaux alléchant sans pouvoir même
boire une bière et commettent disney les
rêves paraît-il devienne réalité
l'alcool est désormais autorisé à pablo
ebook pour des mon procès secte à 620 on
sent un petit peu malheureusement pas ou
non on épouse est venu avec avec ma
fille déjà disney m'a dit on peut pas en
boire devant un restaurant alors dit
jamais je viens registre on va voir
demain on apprenne à part la radio que
pouvaient maintenant consommé de
l'alcool alors je suis aujourd'hui ouais
ça fait la digestion
l'autorisation d'alcool correspond à la
nouvelle stratégie commerciale de disney
le parc a été européaniser pour mieux
répondre aux goûts des clients tel zorro
côtoie désormais [ __ ] pour autant
l'alcool reste tout juste toléré
il est servi dans le restaurant chic du
parc mais pas dans les buvettes ou les
buffets nous allons réserver la
proposition de vin au restaurant qui
servent à la place car c'est plus le
complément traditionnel une nourriture
gastronomique plutôt que de la
nourriture qu'ils fassent bonne qui
s'accommode pas forcément bien reste que
le vin a fait son entrée à disney une
sacrée entorse aux règles du coca roi
boire un petit coup c'est agréable dans
les cafés de paris comme dans le royaume
magique